I really don't we're living in the  moment you're enjoying an unbelievable  era this stuff doesn't happen very often  so when you do end up with a great team  and a great group of guys you just ride  it out for as long as you can and you  enjoy every second of it it's not about  who got the most numbers or you know who  did this who did that we weren't and we  want to win more and so at the end of  the day when you know when we're talking  legacies we just want to be remembered  that's one thing and that's winners man  champions being a Finals MVP I can't  even I couldn't even write that book if  you told me about that when I was eight  years old man so it feels great